yo what is up guys are just prestiged
mad Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video and today we're
looking at some of the hollow dome DLC
new guns that we got there are six new
guns in total so in this video I'm going
to be looking at half of them and i'll
make another video looking another the
other half and so it's going to be quick
little snippets of what i think of each
gun and kind of what each gun is like so
we're gonna be looking at the party line
the boxy and the t4s dash are so let's
look at the party lat first party line
is a door shotgun these are all gonna be
uniques is a Dora incendiary shotgun it
fires a good amount of projectiles five
for the this extra large party line and
it shoots like the contraband sky rocket
grenade as in so when you shoot it
you'll get a bunch of fireworks that
will go off it does have a pretty good a
fire rate for being the shotgun if
you're playing is nisha or anybody that
can get the fire rate up and to say the
shotgun I don't know it's just it's
alright as a fire shotgun by itself it
doesn't stand up too well in terms of
just killing things by itself because so
many enemies have shields so it does
take a long time to get the shields off
but if you're gonna be using this in
tandem with other guns like other
shotguns such as the boxee the box is a
shotgun then it will do pretty well I it
does kill guys fairly fast because it's
fire end does have a little bit of that
contraband skyrocket explosion damage
it's not there's not actual explosive
damage but you get that little log
exploding projectiles that do more fire
damage so you get your normal five shots
or whatever you have for your shotgun I
think it's going to Italy usually be
around five shots and it's gonna be
shooting those guys with the five shots
and then the little sky band rock of
explosions you don't get five explosions
usually it's like two or three
explosions in my experience but yeah um
I think it's a pretty cool shot gun and
it's definitely a good weapon to have in
your kit if you're going with some shock
weapons even don't have any shock
weapons then this is going to be I'd say
use a different gun or not elements
begun to take down the shield of enemy
so next up we have the
boxing of the boxy is a tid your SMG two
door like the previous gun so it's going
to explode when you were loaded you're
going to throw it and it's going to
explode I forgot to mention that about
the party line you'll throw it and it's
kind of it will follow a straight path
and I'll kind of roll up a little bit
and at wal explosion now the thing
that's interesting about the boxy is
that if you reload it before you shoot
all the bullets so as an you reloaded to
do some of the damage like many to do
our smgs are used to do then it's has a
chance of exploding in your face um yeah
you can see there's a little note this
is unstable reloads so it can blow up in
your face if you try and reload it and
that will hurt you and since you
probably have shields on it'll take a
good chunk your shields and that's what
makes this gun kind of odd now one
benefit to kind of counteract this is
that its bullets always bounce off at
whatever they hit so if they hit the
ground they'll bounce off and they have
a chance to go ahead hitting an enemy
this is a pretty amazing skill if you
have it paired with the LA nisha skill
to have projectiles that don't hit
enemies to bounce off and have a chance
of hidden enemies also there's a new
legendary class mod and Phoenicia it
gives plus to that skill so you'd have
even more projectiles bouncing off I
haven't tested this with that but that
would be a really good way to do it so
yeah this is a shock it's a simple shock
SMG and I think it's has a pretty good
fire rate so I think it is a pretty good
weapon to use and so let's get into some
gameplay and you guys so we're gonna see
the boxee in action and you can see just
rebounding everywhere all the bullets
flying everywhere I generally do not use
did your SMGs or to your guns that often
so I don't have an inherent want to just
reload it every time I shoot a bullet so
that I can get all the damage in the gun
if you didn't know to door because they
reload when you because they throw and
throw out like a grenade when you reload
them and
when you reload them you lose all the
ammo that was in that clip all the
unused ammo is is used in damage in the
gun so say I shoot one bullet so there's
I've third three shots I shoot one
bullet and then I reload and the to do
or SMG the boxee hits another enemy
that's going to have the little small
explosion of electricity damage plus all
of the 32 shots that I did not use
because I lose those 32 shots I don't
keep them like four other manufacturers
of guns so you can see that for nesha I
do the unchained skill so I am getting a
pretty nice fire rate bonus and this
thing does pretty good work once you get
up there in the fire rates and you can
see I'm doubting myself I just down
myself with a reload so you can see the
positive and the negative aspects from
this done all in one you can shoot
really really fast but you can also down
yourself and the shooting really really
fast it gets and kills enemies really
fast shock is I'd say the best uh
element because it's can take it shields
and it does a lot of damage to normal
flesh so unlike fire with the party line
which will inhibit you this one will not
inhibit you because the part I can't cut
through shields this can cut the field
and I can't get through flesh so I think
it's it's definitely an interesting gun
I would want to use it with my Nisha
build to see if it's if it can work well
with that then it can definitely a very
powerful gun however it's right now I'm
on the fence since it does burn through
sm GMO like it's nothing but that comes
at the price of shooting really really
fast and lastly we have the t4s dash R
or the Taser now a lot of people thought
this was going to be shocked weapon
however it's a cryo weapon which I'd say
does fulfill its name pretty well so you
can see the red text I haven't been
reading the red text uh the boxee was
something around the long lines up it's
totally a fire extinguisher the party
line was something like exit line gives
excellent and the t4s that r is actually
i can't really read that on my screen
but i think it's i politely request you
do not t for as dash army
come on good sir now this is kind of
reference oh I think it was a meme I
guess I don't know what to call it but
it was a phrase that people used don't
tase me bro but as obviously stated a
little more cordially in this
environment so the Taser consumes to mo
per shot it has a pretty good crit
chance this is 0 twenty-four percent
almost one in four shots will crit and
it's hyperion so the first shot is gonna
be pretty crazy but then you get
increased accuracy and it's pretty well
and one thing I want to mention for
nesha um a lot of times when I'm in my
action skill and I use this weapon every
single shot has the hyperion backlash so
just a forewarning it is pretty
nausea-inducing however because you do
have auto aim it does not affect your
name so that's good I actually do really
like this weapon I think it's a great
weapon each is most r enemies and I've
little 46 since I got this from the
first hollow dome run that I did and it
still Rex enemies are much higher than
its here you can see in action just
mowing down enemies and me getting a
bunch of crazy kickback from basically
every single shot nematic this is going
to be the last game play shot and it is
you can see it just does mode out it is
the fastest mowing down all the enemies
of the three guns that I've seen today
and of the guns that I've used of the
new new six weapons it is the fastest
killing one now granted it run it makes
the boxy look like it is savvy with ammo
usage this like you can have seven
hundred shots of pistol ammo and well I
guess for one I am nisha so do have
increased fire rate and I'm using two of
them and the thing does have really good
fire rate by itself the tasers I just I
mow through these seven hundred shots I
start the battle with seven hundred
shots and I go through it just crazy
fast and if I was just holding this on
full auto the entire time I go through a
much faster so one thing I must say
about this gun is that if you want to
conserve ammo you're gonna have to shoot
and then switch to another gun to kill
when they're cry out however one thing
on another plus i will say is that
everything gets frozen since you're
consumed
2mo per shot and you have a one in four
chance to freeze especially Venetia with
two pistols you're like the chance to
freeze every second is probably at least
five at least like five hundred percent
every second so yeah that's going to be
about it you can see I'm already out of
ammo for that so that's going to be
about it for the video i hope you guys
have enjoyed this uh i was gonna make
this a fairly quick look but i guess I
droned on a little bit longer than I
plan to but whatever so he goes hope you
guys have enjoyed this make sure you
check out my channel for more content
along borland supra sequel and whatever
other stuff that I happen to be doing i
am going to hopefully make a follow up
video to this once i get all six weapons
and i'm going to display all six weapons
and I Magnus well not all sex but the
rest of the six in their magnificence
the the rocket launch are the Plunkett's
and the crybaby that's the other one is
all rifle so yeah I hope you guys have
enjoyed this I'm procedure mad Luigi and
I'll see you all later peace out